I was just watching a YouTube clip on
Metallica when they played to like 1.5
million people in Russia right yeah I
mean it's is that accurate 1.5 million
people have you seen that video I saw uh
I saw something on social media where it
was like this is what 1.5 million people
looks like and then swipe and then this
is what 100 000 looks like and then
swipe and this is like what 1000 looks
like right and and I swiped all the way
through it but then I went back to the
1.5 million people and it didn't look
any different than the 100 000 I I kind
of didn't because you couldn't all those
people into frame it's pretty crazy how
are they how they just ticket sales it
was the first
really big heavy band that had ever
played Russia
91 because it was right after the Black
Album came out Metallica by that time is
arguably the biggest band on the planet
because remember guns was out at that
time and they were doing usual illusion
so metallic and this is before the guns
and Metallica Tour that they did
they got they're out there as before
James got lit up is before the explosion
hit him oh [__] yeah so it was right in
that time frame
they're the biggest band in the world in
the universe at that point every at up
to that point that I get I'd say the
most modern show that had ever been
played in Moscow was the Peace festival
that happened in 89 which was Motley Bon
Jovi uh Cinderella
um I mean it was like [__] Skid Row
was there uh scorpions and they were
doing the the
uh Motley was claiming they were sober
yeah yeah it was well and that was one
of the reasons why they were doing it
was to to promote that and yet then Ozzy
was on it you know and so and Zach tells
all these horror stories about the plane
ride over where everybody was [__]
just
[__] face dude and you're just like oh
my God but I think that was the most
modern show that had been because
remember the curtain was kind of still
on and off at that point yeah 87 yeah so
80 89 the Wall came down yeah yeah
um
so a 91 Metallica hits the biggest band
in the [__] world everybody and their
mom is going to that show you know what
I'm saying because it wasn't like it
wasn't like even 10 years ago where
Russia was kind of a spot on your tour
like you did rush I've played mosque
I've Moscow many times you know not
anymore but at the time nobody did it so
word got out and you think about how big
Russia is you're gonna [__] make your
way to that show you're going to get to
that show so 1.5 honestly in my opinion
maybe a small number because there I
mean there could have been [__] it
could have been like the original
Woodstock where they just stopped taking
tickets and it was just everybody in
their [__] mom coming over you know
the Junior's Farm they're just like
we're going to [__] see this [__]
yeah so good man do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
wipes for your butt hole are available
on Amazon and if you want a real bundle
of a deal you can get Stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole plus Stephen's
butthole destroyer and Stevo's butt
wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now yeah
dude